hey ryan welcome to the world air
podcast i'm james marshall and this
episode was brought to you by puresport
cbd oil
and fortune favors go over to the
waterlab.com website
what a website um and find out how you
can get involved with any of these
juicy discounts off these products but
let's get into this one i'm super
excited to have today's guest on i feel
like this could be one of the most
valuable
episodes yet for any young aspiring
young player
this guest was one of the most gifted
young players that you'll ever see he
made the new zealand under-19s
new zealand under 21s the tasman marco
and the canterbury item cup side
and literally got kicked out of all four
of those sides
he went over to sandon in italy and he
also got kicked out of them
and now he is a player coach for
vincenza
and is an absolute lad he's turned the
corner he's willing to share his advice
it is the gifted one himself robbie
flynn welcome flinny thanks for coming
on
mate how are you mate pleasure to be
here honestly you're an absolute legend
and i'm so
glad i'm on this show now i can't wait i
can't wait to hear your story i know
you've had
i know little bits of your story and i
know it's been some journey so
i'm looking forward to hearing the this
the full story coming from the man
himself but
you're in italy at the moment what's
what's the situation over there with the
coconut i know you guys were hit pretty
hard but
how is it at the moment yeah yeah it's
um it's
basically become normal life now you
know you just wear your mask wash your
hands and
i'm not thinking about too much mate i'm
working um
training hard and just trying to wait
for the season to come so
sure so there's no lockdown or anything
yeah there's like a curfew at 10 o'clock
and bars are like got restrictions and
stuff like that
the rules change every week you know
different zones and stuff like that but
mate you know just keep going yeah and
what how's your season going
ah there is no season there we i
[Laughter]
haven't played rugby for about a year
and a half now so the body's loving it
mate it's absolutely loving it
fully healed i'm 35 years old but i must
honestly i feel about 27
at the moment you know i think i'm
backing my prime after this coronavirus
another 10 years to go maybe maybe you
know you never know
so you'll play a coach now eh so that
must be pretty cool i wouldn't have
really expected you to be
coaching but um look you've turned the
corner and now you're inspiring everyone
around you i would have never expected
that with jimmy um
no yeah i've been playing coaching for
like five years i'm actually having a
year off now because
it's quite hard to make the difference
as a rugby player and to coach them at
the same time so i'm kind of taking a
step back
and just concentrating back on the footy
for maybe my last couple of years you
know so
so we'll get back into the coaching in a
couple of years i think and back to a
full-time player i know you're still
carving it up i see your clips on your
instagram um you've definitely still got
it still got that outline
wait that's that's all i've got though i
just run on that outline since
i can 0-1. on the bounce
on the bounce mat you know that's it
that's all it got me honestly i just do
the bounce and they all fall for the
same trick
and it's a race mate i say go so and i
hope that ball's on the money
that's about it oh it's that easy
anyway but let's get to your journey i
know like i said at the start i know
bits of it but
um take us right back to the start for
you um what was it like growing up as
young robbie flynn oh mate um
growing up well let's get off to the
start so
i was actually born um this is going to
be pretty heavy for
for everybody i was actually born
addicted to heroin like that's pretty
crazy right off the cuff this wasn't my
choice um
uh my mum she died when i was one and a
half
of um heroin overdose my dad he was uh
pretty much a criminal professional
criminal um
so i started off pretty bad you know and
um went into foster care and stuff like
that
and then um eventually after about six
months i think in foster care
i got my grandma i've had 10 boys
she um decided to take number 11 and
number 12 on
me and my brother and in a retirement
legend of a lady mate
legend of a lady to do that for us and
um
yeah she took us in when i was probably
about nearly two years old so i don't
really remember those first years but
apparently they were pretty tough and
you know it was kind of the beginning
mate and then you know once i moved with
my
my grandma you know things they started
to turn the corner and
started yeah just being a kid i suppose
been a happy kid
so yeah that was the very beginning
before i actually
discovered rugby so what's a um heroin
addict look like at a
as a one-year-old how does how does that
even work no
idea buddy no idea right like i've got
nothing wrong with me
you know um i don't know mate to be
honest
i think i was weaned off it i had to be
put in like under
you know a little bit of care when i was
born but
mate to be honest i don't remember and i
don't i've never really asked anyone
i've never had like a
tight enough relationship with my dad or
anyone close to actually
ask the questions of what happened back
in those days but you know
just kicked on and got through it mate
so i survived that got lucky man but
and where was your dad he was in prison
i think um
when i was born so and also when my
mother died he was probably spent about
30 years of his life in prison
so you know i didn't really have a
father i didn't have a father at all so
you know i was just
my grandparents became my parents my
nana pat and bob
now absolutely champions of humans mate
you could
never ask for better bob was a bit
grumpy but he was a legend and um
my nana she was a an angel mate she was
an absolute angel so
she looked after us and taught us good
values as much as she could
so you know tough beginning mate very
tough beginning
and you were brought up in christchurch
am i right yeah
um christchurch born and raised um
had um so sin because i was living
banana you know i was around
she had 10 boys and all um basically
professional rugby players before the
professional era
so i was really involved with rugby
culture mate so like it was awesome for
me i was a kid growing up i was
i was always around rugby man i loved
that man it was all i was all over did
i just play rugby i'd find anywhere to
play rugby the backyard the hallway you
know her brother as well so we just play
rugby all day long and
mate honestly it was a really to be
honest it was a great childhood and
you know i can't complain mate we we had
great times so
you know were you a bit of a
troublemaker
um yeah i was a bit of a troublemaker at
school i was
i was not the best i was i don't know i
just i'd always get in trouble i don't
think i was a troublemaker but
people i just always got the blame for
everything for some reason all the way
through as well you know all the way
through it was
it was always my name that got bored out
i don't know i got a catchy name or
something but
some reason man they it's just my name
that's stuck and everything that got
done was always my fault so
still to this date all right
it was never you classic
but you started off at saint beads
college didn't you and then you went to
shirley was that
was that from behavior uh nah so yeah
so i like mate to be honest
if we go right back mate rugby was just
it was just in me man like
even from the age of five you know i um
i love the game i had so many so much
support around me my uncles and
everything teaching me the game at a
very young age and
went through all the like systems or the
canterbury sort of reps and stuff made
all the teams it's always like the star
of the team
and um got to high school got st beads
high school and there's always star 13s
14s 15
16s and then you know i got to st uh
first 15 and then it kind of started to
wake up for me like whoa man this could
this could really be like a
this could be a future for me and um
yeah school saint pete's college was
where it kind of hit me like whoa man
you know you could play rugby here for a
living because it became professional i
remember watching super rugby like
the first one you know 95 or whatever it
was like whoa man
you know i could turn this into a
profession so i basically gave up on all
my academics and just concentrated on
footy only went to school to eat my
lunch and just play rugby
uh i went to saint pete's and you know
did my thing there i actually
had had a good first 15 year there first
year i made canterbury schools
and um i decided to leave
they actually kicked me out because of
my academics and they said hey come back
um
come back when the new rugby season
starts and i kind of took that like ah
all right let's see and i actually sort
of talked to my mates and created like a
little super team and shirley boyz i
got like ricky tukaki chris mcnickle
cody hippy
we thought hey let's let's take out um
christchurch boys hi let's try to take
those
mofos out you know let's get them so we
created like a super team man we had a
good team brother and we're like let's
build it and um
went to shirley in my second year of
first 15 um
and we ended up actually losing to them
in the final by kick
mate chris mcnichol he uh missed the
kick to win the game it's pretty easy
one too so
still pretty dark on him for that but
honestly awesome but yeah and that's
kind of where you started making your
name you know
and those are the days and then straight
out of um high school
you were into the canterbury academy set
up and you also made new zealand under
19's want to talk about um how you made
those teams
yeah so straight up high school um
second year there i think i made of both
years first i didn't make canterbury
schools and
first year i didn't get a look for nz's
but then second year i gotta look but i
actually um
it's quite a funny story i um i was um
i was gonna probably i could have made
nz schools i think like
just with my talent and i thought yeah
yeah let's go let's go but then they
called on trainings on a sunday
and half by that time i was my second
year at school
uh first of ten and my i was on the
boozer all weekend
so sunday trainings they were just not
gonna they weren't gonna fly with me so
i stopped turning up to canterbury
schools and they eventually dropped me
which gave me you know the boot from nz
and then um that was
kind of the way i looked at rugby back
then i was so stupid thinking back but
you know what was your relationship with
um alcohol coming through
and when did when did you sort of start
drinking and
obviously you talked about uh weak heads
were for the purse so
what when did that start man it started
earlier i
started when i was probably about 14
started pushing up um
and yeah you know i just i never took my
rugby seriously man and i always had
like
an extreme talent i don't know if that's
a word but i had
you know a talent so um everybody would
always kind of like forgive me for
everything i did
and you could kind of get away with
anything so
i just keep riding that wave and um
you know looking back man it's so stupid
you know if i put everything into my
footing
you know anything could happen but i
always keep turning around you know
do bad stuff and then go real good and
then do bad stuff and go real good
but um just yeah thinking of high school
mate it was uh
it was a booze fest and playing the
games
ripping up and then just back to the
boozer ripping up but then somehow
i don't know what happened they called
me into the academy
for canterbury and you know that's a big
deal you know
like but i didn't see it like that i
don't know i don't know why i didn't see
like that i just um
i just looked at it like it was another
day and
it's kind of like well you know well
cool yeah because i think
my whole life everyone's always telling
me you know you're going to be special
you're on research you're going to be
that
and so when all these things happen you
know it was just another day to me but
then like thinking back when i got
called into the category academy after
like school
and stuff i remember even pins or a
penny like call them into office another
one who
told me it was going to be special you
know i remember this meeting one on one
it was like
probably you know you're special you're
a special talent you know you you're
gonna be amazing you know
you're different than the rest and i was
just like man everyone just keep telling
me that and
i never had real guidance because in
their parents so it was always just like
kind of do what you want you know and
they're always going to forgive me
and um yeah when i got caught in the
academic i actually ended up walking out
on the academy i just gave up because of
six o'clock gyms and i was like i can't
go in
you know i didn't realize how lucky i
was to be put in that situation
because i was forever like this
player there or this person that was
just kind of everyone thought it was
going to be great and i didn't really
care
right it was weird man it was so weird i
thinking back to them like
the lack of how much i didn't give a
f you know i just didn't give a f man
and
i always just thought ah someone will
pick me someone will take me eventually
you know
i'll rip someone up i'll rip one game up
and then someone will
pick me and you know that was my
mentality man and looking back man it's
just the stupidest thing that you could
ever do man like
you know like if you young guys out
there if you ever get that opportunity
in life you gotta take it with two hands
and give it
everything you've got like that can
change your life man like
if you get into an academy system and
they tell you to do this do
that you know whereas i was like they
were telling me to lift weights and i
was like
i don't need weights mate i just give me
the ball you know i'll run i'll step
i'll just do
it doesn't matter i don't need weights
what the hell awaits you know
you know it's crazy mate thinking back
so when i got in that first academy
i actually walked out on it and chilled
out my mates
the alcohol wasn't like a problem
everyone thinks like i was an alcoholic
and [ __ ] like that but
i love my booze i love bendering i love
girls you know who doesn't
and um but the biggest problem was
probably my
motivation and my discipline my poor
discipline
and i was never disciplined as a young
fella i never had like a strict thing to
stick to
go to sleep when i wanted i could wake
up when i wanted i could go out when i
wanted to
when i got into these kind of um
professional setups i was like
i was just running the mark mate and you
know
that's how it was that's how it was man
um
you look back and you think [ __ ]
stupid but hey
once you walk down on canterbury is that
when you made that move up to
tasman i think before i came up to
tasman i actually made the new zealand
19
somehow after all that bad behavior
walking on the academy or maybe i don't
know
but somehow i made the new zealand 19's
team somewhere in the mix
who knows why they picked me for the 19s
i have no idea you know if we were going
on
character and all that stuff you know
there's no way i should have been there
but
you know i was actually pretty good at
the gift of the gab
i went good too but i could also talk my
way out of a storm you know
i could always spin it around for some
reason you know i've been surviving mate
you know i'm a survivor
i basically became homeless you know at
the age of 17
18 you know when my nana died you know i
loved my auntie and then i
decided to just you know go out on my
own so from i think the age of 17 18 i
was on my own
so you know i always had to try and
survive somehow some way
so i think with rugby it was the same
you know i could always
turn a coach's head and make him believe
that i was gonna change
you know when i i actually thought i was
gonna change and i was willing to give
it everything but then something would
happen you know i'd get on a bender or
some girls or some some party or
something and then
i'd make a mistake and um yeah that was
just life you know that's basically
my life so you moved up to tasman took
the tasman scene
by storm carving it up with your outside
line scoring tries for will
you made the marco and then you wouldn't
train on a monday because you usually
had the shits you know that you know
that john
you know that story hey jimmy jesus
yeah man so i came up to tasman man
honestly
i came up to tasman because somebody
they offered me
my my agent at the time he offered me
six thousand dollars
and i was like yeah [ __ ] yeah six
thousand dollars that's gonna be fun
what can we spend that on so i actually
signed the contract
and i was like whoa let's go to and
actually a couple of mates are going out
there ricky two coke and uh christmas
nickels yeah so i was like let's go to
tasman man and um
you know i'd already dropped out of the
academy and [ __ ] you know i didn't give
i didn't actually care what i was doing
i was living in the moment mate
i went up there i got my first paycheck
i think i got taxed down for like 4k or
something
and i ended up blowing that in 27 days
and i bought a pair of slippers and a
poster
at the end of it the rest went on the
boozer against the wall
and then i was broke but i still i had a
chance to make the tasman marcos
so i was like whoa let's go on they put
me in the academy as well which i
eventually walked out on as well i think
i gave up on that because
this couldn't be [ __ ] anymore they had
six o'clock gym again but it pisses me
off that six
after you blew that six thousand did you
make the um tasman squad
yeah but it took me a while i um i ended
up making the new zealand 21 team after
all those shenanigans
and um somehow some way they picked me
for the nz21s again
wasn't supposed to make it went up to a
trial
underweight 82 kgs
mate i went up there just like i got
nothing to lose but this is what i will
tell the youngsters out there i
channeled something with no training no
weights i used to hide behind the
pillars in the gym there at tasman and
not lift weights
but i um i channeled something mentally
i use all that fire
all that fuel i should say to feel my
fire
you know from all the the past stuff you
know also my brother he broke his neck
when i was um
in high school and he was the man you
know he was my leader in life and he
broke his neck and kind of disappeared
for a while there so i was left alone
and um i used all that
ammo to just you know mentally prepare
myself for certain games
so when i um got to that game for that
new zealand under 21 stroll i had all
that
loaded and ready to go and i didn't give
a i didn't give a if what was in front
of me i was gonna
just get to that trial line you know
whatever it took so
i got three tries in 40 minutes i only
got 40 minutes and playing canada b and
i just remember every touchdown that's
ripped i was like you ain't stopping me
you canadian mofos
you can't deal with me you know that was
my mindset that was my mindset
and i still use that to this day man i
still tap into my mental you know my
mental is everything to me that's
probably why i'm still getting paid to
play rugby at 35 years old even after
all these mistakes and don't
you know don't get me wrong i've still
made mistakes till these days but i
still just tap into that stuff man and
it's the power of that mental
toughness which i learned to new zealand
but i you know
helped i progressed through it man and
honestly
my thinking back to that trial man i
just that was it man like my nana i have
my mom i had my brother had everything
behind me and
mate just got me through that trial
scored three tries yeah then
i actually i remember sitting down with
cooper the coach before that trial and
he's like
i don't know if we can pick you 82 kgs
you know robbie you know i just made new
zealand 19s too so i was like you know
why not and um but he's just begging me
mate basically in a one-on-one and i was
ah
okay then okay and that fueled more on
my fire you know and i was oh i'm gonna
show you buddy
and anyway i went out ripped it up got
the second troll ripped it up again
you know i actually talked you through
that one same sort of stuff mate one
chance you know that one opportunity
man just no training still man like
trust me i wasn't lifting weights i was
a
i was a tripping wet 80 kgs at the max
you know
so i remember first time straight
through
line break between richard kahu i think
aaron bancroft midfield boom straight
through there boys you know like
that was my mentality man i was like i
don't know and i just
it was all my path it was carrying me
through you know so
i ended up making that team nz21s flew
over to france and
lost in a world cup to south africa and
kind of
did good too in the um in that world cup
but
mate a lot of a lot of shenanigans as
well over there when i was in france i
actually got in so much trouble over
there that actually ruined
ruined my it's actually caused me to
never wear the black jersey again
what did you do just pissed up probably
more than i trained
when i was in france yeah um
just they gave us too much freedom and
mate it was crazy i like those girls
like waiting outside the hotel
like all day every day so i was like
we're stuck in our rooms and there's
chicks outside and it's like
mate i'm going
i had teammates but again if we go back
to right at the start
you know it was always my name that got
dragged through the mud and i'm not one
i'm not a man to bring anyone down so
i took it all on the chin i remember one
time we we um
played our first game we won against
italy i played
got a couple of dots too you know good
game [ __ ] out
stoked as and then um whopper
he called a drinking ban or management i
don't know caught a drinking ban on
the rest of the the tour and i went out
and i got um we went to a club who goes
clubbing when you call a drinking ban i
mean how the hell can you do that it's
just ridiculous so anyway
i was out got seen some girls it's
always the girls man they always
you know it makes me just want to drink
so
i remember just getting on it and um
whopper actually came up to me and the
bar was like let me sniff your glass
and i was like what the [ __ ] here you go
i was like this coke is coke and he's
like
it's not anyway got bought up the next
day he pushed all management out
and it's made me stand up in front of
the room
funny you gotta apologize to the boys
for drinking and mate i broke down on
two years ago
from the front of that new zealand team
man and just so heartbreaking to let the
boys down and
yeah you'd think that would have stopped
me um but it didn't i probably drank
about
seven to eight more times on that trip i
got put in the dirt i got pushed into
the dirty dirties by the end of it
so at the start i was like competing for
a starting spot you know i was
playing good footie before the end
wasn't the dirty dirties and then once i
got in the dirty duties and i was just
on it like all the time i was living it
up you know i'm gonna live in the moment
sort of guys i'm like
i might not ever be back in france so
i'm gonna [ __ ] live this [ __ ] up
and anyway but what was special about
that trip was
you know make a normal person bloody
screw the head on was um
you know what the feedback from the
management was like
cooper the coach he never forget this
man he told me
come into his office one-on-ones you
know and he's like
you're the most individual brilliant
player in this team
you know i was like you know that's in
new zealand under 21 team mate this team
was stacked eh
right super i was the only non-super
rugby player in the back line
and i was the most individual brilliance
in the coach's eyes
and then hori the trainer was like he
called me in too they're all trying to
change my ways you know because they
could see me going on that downhill
slope
he's like flinny mate i mean you look at
my side to the other
you know look at him man do you think
he's bitter there i'm not yeah he's
probably is he's [ __ ] massive and
black and fast and strong and i'm just
like this little kid
he's like you're so much more talented
than him no you can
achieve so much more than him in your
arabic career
and you know two days later we're in the
germany he's like give me three pushes
and three pulls
i'm like nah i'm all good i'm not that
[ __ ] hey
i'm on nz21s tour just refusing to do
weights
like i'm gonna do i'm gonna do this my
way with my talent my skills
sure i don't know why the hell i was
like that man but i just was i
i just i just was but you're always so
confident by the sounds of it you always
had that confidence in your ability you
knew you were like
one of the best players you could rip
anyone up and so how did you get that
confidence and
where did that come from because if you
added that with your if you started
training [ __ ] you could have been you
could have literally
been anything well actually you made old
goody
he told me that he was like mate with
your [ __ ] skill and everything like
you just need to train that i don't
forget that action
but i don't know man i just i don't know
i mean from a young age i suppose people
always tell you you're going to be great
you're going to be an all black you're
going to be that you're going to be less
sort of maybe you mess with my head a
little bit you know and i didn't need to
work more and
i think that was the biggest mistake
like when some meetings in 21s and 19s i
already thought that i made it
probably when i actually hadn't there's
so much more work to do
you know like so that's only in the
beginning like thinking back
whereas in my head i was like oh yes
i've done it i'm rich i can
get out of this poverty life you know i
can support myself
but the truth is that's only the
beginning yeah you know that's when
you've really got to work on your craft
and and get better and better and better
every day and you have that opportunity
because you're now a professional
so you have every day to work on it and
work it and work on it whereas when
you're not a professional you don't
and that's the mistake i made you know i
just said i'm good enough now and
you know and i just that was it man that
was
that was a mistake man that was the
biggest mistake thinking i already made
it before i had
obviously took you so long to realize
because
the same things kept happening hey like
you would you'd work hard you might see
the light for a bit
start training hard and then um you'd
get straight back to it
you'd get away sniffing to a side and
then you you'd fall into the same traps
always mate that was it like the amount
of bounce backs i've had is
so many so much and um in my rugby
career you know it's been up and down up
and down up and down
it's just always been the same thing
mate you know
training hard ripping up mistake mistake
mistake down
you know and it goes back to the same
thing like
once you make it you just gotta keep
going and
that was that was probably my um i
celebrated too early
i think and i love celebrating you know
so anytime i would achieve something
i'd celebrate you know like [ __ ] yeah i
made it man
i made it you know but the truth is it
was just the beginning yeah you know
and it's actually once you get there
it's so hard to hold
you know because you've got these other
young bucks coming through coming
through coming through but
yeah man that's a tough thinking becca
it's tough it's very
tough thinking back how stupid i was man
and you because you signed with tasman
for four years but you definitely
weren't at tasman for four years so what
happened there
i think it was one year and then the
game in three years so
one when i made new zealand 21s i think
they you know
they sort of wanted to wrap me up and
wall you know and kind of
blood me in and make sure i was gonna
you know perform for them and not get
injured because i was pretty small
but they wanted to look after me and um
yeah they tried they did their best to
be honest they did their best
they honestly they got everything around
me they tried to even um
give me home support who's that that
famous
softball player and tasman yeah i think
so he
offered to take me in to his home let me
live with them and stuff like that
you had like mike crawford like doing
bending over backwards man like the
things they did man was
crazy i had to try and nurture my talent
and try and you know get me not just
that but just look after me
you know like living overseas man you
don't have to be special in how they
look after their players man it's so
cool and
yeah i mean they tried everything but
you know
just wasn't to me just wasn't to be
jimmy
so then what happened post tasman so
tasman after tasman i actually decided
to go off contract and to prove them
wrong i said no guys come on give me
another chance you don't have to give me
a contract but i'm going to prove to you
that i can do this you know i've changed
my ways i've stopped drinking or you
know
go hard on the training and they said
whatever you know we'll see
so i was like okay so i did man i lived
at my girlfriend's house
amber dallas you know her and um we um
i trained man i trained my ass off
roland dallas looked after me
you know i looked after me like my dad
and i would wake up every morning
mike fraser from whoever paid for my gym
membership
and i would wake up every morning bike
to the gym every morning
maybe every second but i was strict you
know i was i'm doing this man
and i would train next to the tasman
marcos so i'd be on the other side of
that gym you know
split yeah yeah and i would train on the
other side and i'd be like no
and i mean i just did that for like six
months i think
and then the trial came finally i played
a season with whoever i think it was my
phrase it was disremore coin
keeping me alive survival mode and um
yeah um the troll cam
had a blinder do you remember that again
do you see that your brother actually
probably uh
your brother actually probably outplayed
me which was [ __ ] disappointing
um he did actually maybe it was close me
and him were
probably the standouts and um anyway i
um
finished the trial happy i was like yeah
i'm going to make this because it
behaves all year
yeah you know it's going to be good and
nick flat came out to me i was out on
the boozer
that night and he comes up he's like oh
i've seen the team squad you made it
you made it i said yes say that's
back in there back get me let's
celebrate
my brother just got off a boat with two
of his mates crook dogs right
and he's like let's get on a bender we
got on a bender
that night i swear to god i met some
girls they like come home with us
jumped in their car and these boys they
see me leaving ditching right
smoke bombing they jumped all over her
car on top of it round
on the windscreen everything [ __ ] her
car up bad
right she rings the tasman rugby union
the next day
says robbie flynn jumped all over my car
put two thousand dollars worth of damage
into my car
i want my money back beven or someone
heard the phone call whoever received
that
gone cut see you later that was my
chance again so
i worked that whole year for that
i did nothing as well i just jumped in
the back of a car with a girl
and these boys seen me leaving thought i
was ditching and jumped all over her
because robbie mountain that's him and i
was playing poker at the pub and i was
still waiting for this call because all
nick flack told me i was like where's my
call i knew i made it i played good you
know i'd been good
i was i was trying you know that never
happened man and then i finally got the
news what were you doing
we got a phone call blah blah blah so
that was that was the end of tasmania
that was the end of tasmania the bender
oh the costly benders so many benders at
bad times but i didn't even do anything
i didn't even do anything wrong man
i pulled a bird give me a break you know
give me a break
so then what happened post tasman um
post tasman right so tasman blew out
yeah tasman blew out but i actually
walked out on that too as well i um
i um it was six o'clock gym still so
pissing me off
it comes back again trust me it comes
back in with a contract offer
um but anyway i went back to
christchurch i had a bang ankle
uh i was playing stoke and shawnee big
or someone like that
i was just trying to win the game and um
i [ __ ] i went too hard out and i
ended up doing my ankle
and that's why i actually walked down
the contract because i didn't i didn't
know what to do but i was trying to fake
it like i was in tasmania but i was
actually in canterbury
i just wanted to go home and um i was
trying to fake like i was still in
tasman so they're still paying me
it's terrible behavior anyway they
figured it out that i wasn't there
and um i went back home and made to be
honest
it was i was sleeping on a mate's couch
um you know went and just
pissing up having fun banging girls and
just living life
i gave up on rugby for about a year
there you know just gave up had enough
i was over i was just done i just yeah i
just wanted to play with my i was still
playing i love the games i was playing
socials i think i was playing like div
two or something
and then i um oh then cannot be offered
me a contract oh this is another
this is another mess made academy
offered me a contract and i said yes all
right how much are you going to give me
this so they give me a couple hundred
bucks so
i don't think it was a week even i think
it was like a month
i was like okay i need anything i'm in
survival mode
i was also getting some off shirley oh
yeah surely i
went to them they hooked me up something
i'm a survivor of the rugby like pure
rugby i've done it my whole life people
will pay me money for my talent so i'll
exploit that so
surely you'll hook them up so maybe
they're mid camera i can't play
heartland couples like swedes and get
this played like one game
maybe two i don't know went [ __ ] out of
shape terrible wasn't in shape that's
one thing you have to be
in shape i started to learn that i was
like whoa you actually have to be in
shape
to play good i just was like oh my god i
can't believe this i've never thought
about it
and um yeah just and then
this is what happened my brother he came
home he was this fisherman he hired a
hotel in
christchurch and some flash hotel room
he was trying to impress some girl
same mates around same crew we got on a
bender
um i didn't show up for the game the
next day if i met cannery versus
somebody i just did a no-show i teach
josh lindsay my mate hey mate he was a
you only get three imports he was the
fourth on reserve
you've got to go to that game you have
to go that game for me
he couldn't play anyway because he
didn't register him but that was it
two games and then um i never played
again i went to all the trainings but i
never got
i never got to play again did you ever
feel bad doing stuff like that
or did you just not really care um 100
mate it used to it used to deliver me
mate honestly
i i think just when i was in those
moments of drinking and having fun
you know even before i would get drunk
i'd be like i can't do this i can't no
i can't do this but people around me
would just
you know talk me into it and that's like
what you know a big lesson now is in
life is
you know your support crew around you is
so important man it's so important like
you've got to be around people that want
you to
succeed like if you look i look at back
at you when you're in tasman you heard
um goody man he
took you under your wing and oh i look
back and i'm like
jealous almost in my mouth i wish i
listened like goody wanted to take me
under his wing too you know
and i was like but i wish i did you know
you must have had one of the bendiest
arms to be asked to come out on the
pistol
rubber mate the rubber estimate the
rubberist of them all
and could go for the longest i wouldn't
stop i'll just keep going
once it started i was like let's go
let's go till the end and i was full of
fun too you know i'm always for fun
yeah people enjoyed it people enjoyed my
company i suppose you know
so gee so after about 10
blowouts already you somehow made your
way into the canterbury
item cup squad yeah one of the
powerhouse
teams of new zealand rugby and here's
robbie flynn who's blown about 30
chances he's in there
how did that happen ultimate jimmy
you've actually got a big part to play
in this and this is going to be crazy
for you but remember that sevens
tournament that we played
woody and you yeah you ripped up to
shreds though
it was like under i was in awe of how
you played that man i was just like [ __ ]
this guy's on the next level like just
everything you did even off the field
you're so professional
doing your stretches and i was like man
this is
crazy man and your performance on the
field was like
holy i'm supposed to carry that team you
know jimmy i was supposed to carry that
team that day
and i was on your back and i was like
thank you god because i was so unfair it
was i've just been on probably a
four-month bender and i was like oh
thanks jimmy
thanks mate you know hello because i
always felt like people were watching me
right robert flynn's got to do something
special you know he's got to win you
know he's the guy you know but
that day man i'm grateful for you but
not only for that for what you
made this is going to sound crazy to you
but you inspired my life a little bit
there right because i thought man
if you if you've done that and that
short amount of time
you excelled so fast in a couple of
years
i was like whoa man just through
training hard listening to
the support around you and just being
professional and disciplined
man i sort of just said i have to do
that too
you know so from i sort of brushed off
the the pride of me not
getting us through that tournament of me
not being the man you know it was hard
for me bro
you know and um and i just sort of
started training again you know and i um
i moved in with my ex ex girlfriend's
mom
and um trained the house down bro
she would feed me the ex-ex-girlfriend
moved to australia
so she said she'll um she'll you know
let me board there for a bit
and i just trained man i'd run
i had to get a job i played um for
surely club
and i was working in like a woodwork
place whatever you call them
yeah no i was running to work i was
running home stopping off at the gym
pumping iron running back eating healthy
going to the gym i repeated and repeated
and repeated and repeated for that
few four months maybe and i was playing
footy at the same time and my
form at club level just went like like
crazy bro like i started shredding
everyone like it was like
i was just like whoa i couldn't even
blame myself sometimes you know
and playing for a [ __ ] team and ripping
up the top dogs and nearly putting them
like
competing with them you know yeah and
yeah then i
remember i was working as well and i got
the phone call
from rob penny i kind of knew it was
coming
i kind of knew it was coming because i
was playing so well so i know these
mother these guys are going to give me
another chance
um hey it's rob benny i was like
what's up
and i was like the best moment of my
life and he's just like
his first thing was like we're going to
give you another chance
but can you do it and i was like yes
yeah of course of course of course of
course and then
yeah man got sort of just walked out on
site
just like [ __ ] yeah oh my god
i'm playing against hawke's bay this
weekend i made it again
you know i've made it it's time to
celebrate the thing
i didn't know i didn't thought it was
too big of a deal mate it was too big
i was playing the canopy brothers on my
dream all times
yeah yeah after that phone call yeah i
went into camp
camp whatever you call it snails just so
cool being involved in the environment
bro it was like it was my dream bro
because i was in the academy and i
always said once i get behind those
gates you know like rugby
uh rugby park you know it's like shut it
off i said
it's a dry pass you don't think you know
once i get back in those gates man
i'm not gonna mess this up you know so
once i got back in there i was i was
straight on point you know yes sir yes
sir yeah
it was a stress you know because i don't
want to be late for anything i was just
trying to be perfect you know
and um yeah did it man i had a really
good um i didn't play too many games it
was obviously behind like sunny bill
and all that [ __ ] but it was good
you know so what happened well i trained
really well
i used to i used to put fear in them at
training you know
even sunny once said don't run around me
you know
but uh it was like that brian but yeah i
got back in there
i got back in there i was pretty proud
of it actually mate part of me getting
back in there was
i was with the bees with the canterbury
bees and we had a little game of touch
against the mpc
team and i smoked stevie brett on the
outside two times in a row in front of
turbine matson
and score tries in a game of touch
stevie if you're listening as you
remember that thank you bro i think you
let me run through he's a good mate
i think he let me go i i think he you
know you want to hook me up
and um then this is
we had like back line launches against
each other
and i i had karen from the tier 12 and
the b team
yeah and lindsey at 10 you know karen
lindsey
and i was older than them right so i
took the charge i took the lead
i started calling the calls you know i
was like id id you know oh yeah
[ __ ] whatever whatever you know i
can't remember the moves back in new
zealand now but yeah
i started calling the shots and tabs was
right there i was just trying to impress
them so all those
years of um being them not ass licker i
decided at this moment i'm gonna lick
some ass
you know calves look at me look at me
calling these moves look at me
and mate he fell for a day and he picked
me he took me in he called me in
he told pence to ring me and boom it
worked mate
you know but i was working hard mate so
i did deserve it you know i did deserve
it i was working bloody hard mate like i
was going
full turn so so what stopped you from
still being at canterbury calving up
where does it all fall down
for well actually after the first year
and i had like i was
benching playing games for the bees but
man i had some good performance with the
bees that uh
ripping up so otago um they actually
offered me a contract like a full
contract flew me down and gave me the
whole thing you know i never really
experienced that too you know
i was like whoa i'm back and i flew me
down and show him around the stadium and
stuff like that
to me that was like wow you know and
that's showing real interest offered me
a full contract npc whatever
and like highlanders wider and then i
had to have a meeting with canterbury
um with tears amphibians and the coffee
shop down the road from
rugby park and they were like no through
is going to make the all blacks
so you know you're going to be starting
13 for canterbury next season
well you know i can't turn that down
that's that's that's my
dream mates i started one game the first
game
i ran for the shield match against north
canterbury froome didn't make the all
blacks i sat on the bench
or in the stands for the rest of the
season turned that down
and then even when everybody was injured
the tabs he wouldn't pick me at 12
because of the third and he picked
takarae
[Laughter]
he picked him at 12 and it was like a
massive insult to me i took it
badly and i kind of walked out again
i walked out true i did i said now [ __ ]
this i'm done
you can't just pick takurei norton who's
number nine
against me a specialist midfield he'll
train my ass off to be here and now give
me this opportunity [ __ ] you i'm done
yeah and i started making up lies and
excuses for not being at training
yeah true oh [ __ ] so then what happened
after canterbury it was a weird exit
because
pins was like he kind of fired me rob
penny fired me while we were on the piss
so i didn't really know if it was real
so they still invited me to the um
they still invited me to the to that
prize
event and i turned out the prize you
know sheepish as they come like i said
at a table of pens after everything was
done i didn't say a word i was like
you know like you know how scared you
are coach doesn't stop man i was
petrified like
i don't know what i'm saying i was
waiting for him to say anything he
didn't say anything
you know and i was like oh okay it's
done
it's time to go so um called on a mate
held um i went down to southam i stayed
with the doc
finlessons you know those guys legends
they took man
they said have a crack at the stags and
um start our place
so i went down there it was a lot it's
like i've been pushed all the way down
down the island you know get out
i'm nearly gone and um yeah i went down
there mate and it was actually really
enjoyable i
actually really liked it and i knew i
had to change for the coaches i knew i
had to show them that i
was like not onto the boozer anymore not
that the booze was the problem in canada
in the last two years
it was i don't know what the i don't
know but anyway it was just um
it was weird anyway so i went back down
there
and i was like [ __ ] it i have a crack at
the stags
and play club footy and get a job i had
to get a job cutting trees in the hill
mate have you ever done that
no never that would have been tough
don't kills your legs i had to like go
to training after and it was just
ridiculous
but anyway i um i hated it i actually
quit that job
and then i got another job made the club
get me another job there i was hooking
me up
and um clubs always hook you up yeah and
you're kind of like me like rogue
running around they always hook you up
don't worry and um then i
tried yeah so i was going to have a
quick stays man it was going really well
i was training hard doing the same
things and didn't canterbury eating
clean not drinking just a couple of
times
yeah then i got a phone call from tabs
table matson from canterbury yeah
just before stags was going to get
selected and i probably would have been
starting for stags to be honest
i'd convince them that you know i was
turning the corner and i was in good
shape
i think they were gonna take me because
when you i think when i went down there
i was kind of like
the level's a little bit easier i'm not
saying i don't know if that's going to
sound bad but
you know stairs compared to canterbury
you know it was just a little bit easier
you know i felt like i was a little bit
higher level than them
as talent-wise and stuff so you know i
was loving it i was
really expressing myself down there in
trainings and
dominating and then yeah i was like i'm
going to play for the stags third and
then i'm going to get my way back into a
super rugby contract not that i ever had
one but that was you know i was going to
[ __ ] about that i'm going to get the
highlanders you know still keeping that
dream alive but i was only
like 25 you know and i was still like i
didn't even reach my prime yet so i had
all this talent to give and
it was still really good so of course if
i keep my behavior right and talked well
you know they were going to give me
another chance you know you can't you
can't say no to this talent brother
so and then tabs rings me and
out of nowhere right had his name saying
because tabs too don't know why but i
never forget it hey man what's up
what are you doing fellaini i'm in uh
i'm in southern
um what are you doing with rugby you're
still playing rugby yeah man i'm in the
best shape of my life all right mate do
you want to go to italy i was like
yeah mate honestly i swear to god i i
said yeah let me think about it for a
night you know being professional as but
i lay back in that bed i was in bed and
i thought
imagine the [ __ ] that was honestly
the first thing that went through my
head i swear to god
i just thought that honestly i thought
imagine the puzzle
so um that's gonna sound terrible but
that's the truth
and yeah i rang come back the next day i
said yeah let's go had a skype call with
coach
a month later but oh yeah the finland's
there doc downs out mate and all the
times man they helped me out they got me
there i was like in debt and stuff i
also like committed like crimes and [ __ ]
not
anything serious but you know stupid
[ __ ] like pissing in public drink
driving i had all these fines and
they helped me sort it out with the
lawyer they they they helped me out like
you wouldn't believe man so many
people help me out my arabic career man
it's unbelievable i'm missing so many
people here and um
yeah i just decided to go and then i was
off mate i was on the plane i actually
left
illegally yeah so i wasn't actually
allowed to leave i still had pd
hours to go
so so stuck i went over there i got
arrested when i got back but oh
that's another story and um yeah so i
went over there i
went over to italy it was amazing
it was so cool i was just like oh yeah
it was like it was the best mate and
things went well
things went really really well like not
for the first bit because you had to
adapt to the level of play and
style but i just just found my feet
started carving up
kind of made a name for myself like in
that first year yeah
everyone was kind of yeah just scored
his tries bro you know and a few
magazines and then the papers and [ __ ]
and
what was the level like i'd say it's
like between like
it's different because there's like four
good teams and the rest of them are
average so i'd say like between the item
and
club rugby canterbury i know that's sort
of that level at that level at each lens
i don't play that level play level down
now you know yeah
so yeah man it was nice bro i went to a
little town called sendana
just playing rugby um
eating nice food drinking cheap booze
mate
nothing changed though i i got i
probably got worse
i was bendering like you wouldn't
believe it but you just got away
feels a little bit easier yeah yeah the
rubber is a little bit easier
and yeah i found my ways to kind of
it's a soccer mentality here so if you
score tries
you're the man yeah so i figured that
out i was like oh so all i got to do is
really just
kind of figure out how to beat my man
and get a couple of dots and then i'm
good you know
so figure that out did that do that for
the second year i got fired for
uh i did my ankle i actually nearly made
the uh treviso team
they called me in and they were ready to
offer a contract
but i had a injury on the ankle and it
never healed probably because i boozed
up and traveled
instead of healing it 100 i was walking
around like europe with this big fat
ankle
it wasn't even broken and instead of
trying to recover i was like nah [ __ ] it
let's go on a ticket
and um they stopped ringing so i lost
that contract
so when i got fired from the first job
there i lost the benetton one the
senator one i was back in new zealand
and i was like all right
i think i'm done now i think this is it
yeah this could be it
and then i get a another phone call from
a mate who played with me in cinema
uh ricky robuski it's pretty much saved
my ass man because no one else is going
to touch me
no one no i don't you know but he played
with me as i suppose he thought it
sort of seemed my talent was like hey if
we could get this guy you know we could
get this guy
and um yeah they got me man and when i
got there i just played as a player and
they kind of
offered me like a coaching sort of play
a role and it was kind of when i started
to change man
you know i started to really look at
rugby and go like hey
you can make a difference here you know
like
with all that you've learned from new
zealand and all through your life
and you know i started to mature as well
you know i was aged i was like 28 or
something so
yeah yeah i started turning the corner
man i started going right this is really
the time where you this is your last
chance
there's nothing else otherwise you're
going back to new zealand and you're
working
as a laborer you've got no skills you've
got nothing else
you've got nothing so this is your last
chance and
i took it seriously bro and started
coaching and took like
i just took everything i learned from
canterbury because i had like aaron
major and tamar matson and
penz and the coaches you know and i just
kind of like
went through my brain jot it all down
and just just kind of copy it you know
yeah and then teach all the boys that
and they loved it mate
it took off and actually made them
perform better and i got
satisfaction from that and made me go
like whoa you can actually change
people's lives here right not just on
the field but off the field
and yeah that was when it kind of
started turning man and then so all that
[ __ ] behind me was like
what an idiot but now then i kind of was
like hey it all happened for a reason
but yeah do you look back on your career
thinking
uh that sort of italian lifestyle suited
you like
being able to just chill get on the
purse have fun
or do you sort of look back and think
man i missed an opportunity to be one of
the
greatest players ever within a hundred
percent
second one i [ __ ] i messed up jimmy
like i could have been if you think
about it if i
worked on my craft every single day you
know every single day
i never worked on my craft i never did
you know i do the training the minimum
if i worked on it every single day you
know could have been
i could have who knows you know it's in
my dna man you know it's in my blood you
know
i was supposed to be something special
with rugby and
i regret it it's a big regret and
i just don't know man but also i also
don't have any regrets i think it's
gonna work out and the better in the
long run
because if when you make those mistakes
you actually learn more
so now as i'm matured and i'm 35 it's
like hey you've learned i can use all
that
yeah there's a lot of mistakes i can use
all that like when i'm talking to kids
man i get too deep
you know like when i'm talking to rugby
players and trying to coach i'm
too invested now i just want to help
them or
you know i'm just so passionate about it
because
i think when you make that many mistakes
and it's hard to explain i don't know
how to explain it i'm not there yet but
yeah i don't know i don't know i don't
know jimmy what do you think
i think you're going to be one of the
greatest coaches ever
so much to teach maybe yeah maybe man
i'm thinking that two-man night
honestly and i love this i need like the
game gave me so much man it saved my
life
honestly it saved my life man it's such
a beautiful game it's so
beautiful like if you look at what it
does to people
and how it it just creates culture and
mate if i listen to everybody that
coached me and
tried to change me or help me grow man
you know i want to be a special human
you know if everybody listens to that
we've got a lot of special humans in the
world so
my rugby is a beautiful game and it
creates beautiful people like yourself
so
oh 100 mate you're a legend so now that
your journeys
your path of your journey sort of
changed now you're looking back
reflecting
any advice for young players coming
through
talented players especially their
talented ones who
are coming through any advice for them
on what not to do or
what they should do oh mate i mean
what would you say to the young fellas
coming through um
probably if you ever get an opportunity
to feel lucky
to to to get that opportunity don't take
it for granted you know like that's
probably the biggest thing i learned in
my life and
give it everything you've got yeah if
you're really passionate about rugby if
you're not then okay that's not your
thing but if you are
wake up and think about it and do it all
day
go to sleep thinking about embrace it
enjoy it as well
you know don't see it as a burden like i
kind of did in my life but
really enjoy it because it is so fun
there's nothing funner
than actually playing rugby being around
your mates and that can be a a bloody
career now you know how cool is that you
can run around the
field or the ball and all the other
perks that go with it and just
you know it's a beautiful beautiful
thing and
train hard that's got to be one because
if you do train hard and eat healthy
it makes a massive difference which is
something that took me a long time to
realize
have you are you how's your training now
do you train hard now or
yeah i do in and out you know i'm not
always on the go yeah but you know i'm
like
i like to think i'm like a ufc fighter
you know like if
if there's getting a seasoning coming up
i'm i'm getting i'm cutting down
weight and i'm getting ready for it yeah
you know in the off season i might blow
out not too much mate i'm actually a
qualified nutritionist now oh yeah
yeah so i've actually studied all that
stuff and
i actually you know i i have my cheat
meals all the time but
if i'm coming up to a game you know i'll
tone down i'll get the right weight
going and
because it makes a difference but if i
um if i go into the game a little
slightly a little bit heavy
i'm not going to be the same player yeah
you know just with a little fraction of
fat so it's really important to me now
to really get
that down and really concentrate on that
sort of stuff and training and power
power
power
training man that's the key man you
gotta be fast you gotta be explosive you
gotta get your diet right and then you
ma it's the game changer basically you
know it is if you're not doing that then
you're screwed you're just gonna be a
bit of a slug so
yeah you're gonna feel lethargic and
stuff like that so is nutrition
something that you
want to get into post rugby
um yeah i just studied it because me to
be honest
my biggest dream is to just coach and
not just coach but mentor and know
everything not know everything i don't
know at all but just be able to help
people with everything
if if they're on if they're on that
journey to become the best rubbing
player they can be
you know so stuff off the field
nutrition gym stuff you know i want to
have all the tools
you know to help change people's lives
or not change but help them grow
you know so that's probably why i got
into that i just want to be able to
you know help people so and to me that's
a big part of it nutrition i never
looked at nutrition when i was younger
now it's probably a big um
big downfall you know but it's so
important mate it's
it's a big big big thing so and you're
obviously having a massive influence on
a lot of the
players over in italy especially looking
at some of the questions a lot of them
have been
inspired by playing with you or you've
taught them a lot over there so
that must be a pretty cool feeling yeah
it is man i love it um
yeah that's cool man i'm still a player
um i went through the player coaching
and it's quite hard to balance
so if you put too much into your
coaching and your plane fades away a
little bit and vice versa
so i went hard out on the coaching for a
couple of years and i actually nearly
got
kind of never like pulled me in for a
meeting like what's going on with your
plan
i'm like well just i'm working overtime
on everyone else you know give me a
break i was just catch past trying to
put people in space and
you know you can't really do that over
here you've always got to be making a
difference but um
yeah it's mate it's a great mate i love
it i just i think
something happened to me man i started
coaching i just realized this is my
thing eh
this is this is what makes me feel good
i think i don't know if it's about me
though but i just
enjoy helping people get better
at rugby but just not rugby just life
you know because it goes hand in hand
you know something that i got told over
and over and over and over again
but i didn't understand that until you
had to start trying to coach it and then
you're like oh my god it's so true
it's so true you know
yeah so that's cool man oh good jeez
that's good stuff
what a journey to reflect on but anyway
we've gone to the instagram as always
and we've got a heap of questions from
you really i didn't think anyone would
know me like
you know with the kind of guys you've
had on here you know it's like
i'm a bit intimidated okay
first question um tell us the story
about the nickname
the cat just the cat because i got nine
lives
everybody keep giving me another life
mate and also in tasmania
i had the shits every monday so i was
given my um like my i didn't get a cap
for tasman i was in the training squad
for like two or three years i think
i only get a cap because i never turned
up on mondays or tuesdays sometimes on
vendors
and always ringing same excuse i've got
the shits i've got this [ __ ]
oh god they can't you know they can't
they can't go wrong someone told me that
gave me that piece of advice and i went
with it for a
good year and i i never went training on
a monday
even when i got my debut finally against
auckland
and um mate that's another story i got
jammed by jerome kino like
you wouldn't believe that like probably
the most embarrassing thing i've ever
had happen i ended up like that
with my arms crossed going try and
tackle them standing there escort under
the sticks anyway then i got the next
game against canterbury
and you'd think that would kind of push
me to train harder like yeah let's get
the next game
and um i also have bonuses if i played
more games so
but then i ended up getting on a bender
after the canterbury game and
not turning up monday tuesday i might
have even missed wednesday to be honest
just because i had the shots
and then you know i didn't make that
team against hawke's bay i think it was
they had my name on the ticket and sione
he had to take take my spot but he had
my name on his ticket or something like
that oh yeah
the benders geez but never ending
holy i love them okay
tell us a story why you didn't play
number nine when you started playing
rugby
oh i was easy one because there was a
there was a girl there and you know
she wouldn't get tackled so she got to
play nine and i didn't otherwise
i would have been one of the greatest
nines to ever walk this face of the
earth i swear to god
i will still i i'm still ready to
transition man as soon as i lose my
speed i'm going at night
i'm going to do another few years at
night just got to work on my bad side
pass off the deck and i'm like i'm
golden
oh man i'm sniping i'm snipey as they
come
imagine me sniping around there right
jimmy but you can't imagine it man i'm
dangerous yeah it's tough to defend i
wouldn't want to play outside you too
often though
yeah i'm taxing all day i'm having a
quick
crack and maybe you'll get it
okay you've got this one a few times um
it's about your nickname megatron what
part of you is called the megatron and
why
well actually if we go back i think like
because i was born addicted to heroin
i had a few deformities in life so i had
a third nipple
and the other one was a gigantic penis
they started calling me megatron
small balls though real small balls
couple of good deformities
oh that's good stuff okay uh most
successful pickup line
in the early 2000s early 2000's want to
pump
definitely want to pump just used to
race to right like a hundred girls i
actually did a challenge on
tinder i think i was let's try 100 girls
want to pump on a pump on a pump on a
pump
[Laughter]
okay how many hearts have you broken
oh a few not that many it's just a
couple but you know
i've actually learned about that in life
too you know if you have relationships
with girls
try not to hurt them you know as much as
you can because you know
it does you know it's not good i don't
know how to talk about this but
i see how i actually i usually stop
having a girlfriend for um many many
years because i don't want to break any
more hearts
so i'm sure yeah i just stopped having a
girlfriend i got one
yeah i'm a bit we've been together six
years and she just broke up recently so
it's been a nice breakup yeah oh that's
good back in the game i'm back in the
game
that's it okay next question would you
rather take a crash ball or a bounce
ball
oh come on mate do we need an answer i
haven't taken a crash ball since 1984.
bounce all day okay
what are the keys to a well executed
flinny scrum move
things there's always the same moves
there's one two dummy cut out ball oh
you're on the bounce one two dummy cut
out because usually when that 13 sees
the cut happening he turns his head in
and then at that moment i do a little
bounce
oh gosh that 10 puts them put some money
on the ball on the money and then it's
like come on catch me if you can
winger turns his hips on through winger
shuts and i give the ball
too easy right i made it i made a living
off that move
i've made a living for eight years off
pins rob penny actually said
because i was like can i be like can we
do this move and he's like have you ever
done it against anyone good
and i think i actually tried it on
andrew goodman
i'm wondering he got me the eye get me i
thought i'd get him on that one but he
didn't get back just like blue laces i
think if we did it again he'd fail
on that too okay
can you ask him if he's ever been fined
for swimming in the fountain
of rome oh no that was when i first got
to send them that because like you know
in new zealand how you get nude all the
time do we still get nude all the time
someday yeah i used to get naked all the
time so it was kind of nice
i um i got over to uh italy and
you know there's a fountain and just got
oh that's another one i've actually
jumped in a couple of fountains nude oh
yeah the one in rome yep we got
yeah too many fountains too much jumping
in fountains
too many stories on that
big fines as well if you get caught you
get like a 300 euro fine or four
hundreds
did you get away with that one oh you
got away nah i walked off i walked off
but a couple of boys did so
walked off nude nah nah i had my undies
on right so i went
jumping in my undies and i was so drunk
that i forgot
that i jumped in the fountain and i had
my hands on my jeans started seeping
through
and i thought i pissed myself i was like
standing in the next bar like oh [ __ ]
i've pissed myself
i can't believe i pissed myself what an
embarrassment but i forgot that i jumped
in the lake before mondays
okay last question if you could go back
as a 19 year old robbie flynn what would
you do
as a 19 year old listen to
everything everybody ever told me train
my ass off every day wake up
train wake up train pass kick
craft might like build my car honestly i
would honestly i would become the
ultimate machine of rugby i swear to god
i would but
you give me another crack at that i
would be jimmy
but i would make cause if you get you
realize after you lose it
like you get one chance eh you get one
talent and
you should use it as much as you can
there's so many people with less talent
than me that
do better than me you know it's like
[ __ ] just imagine if i just
just imagine if i just went hard out you
know i took it to the next level and
trained every anime
could have been amazing could have been
who knows you know the
this who knows man so that's that's one
thing i definitely would have done
stopped drinking as well and
probably cut my dick off
[Laughter]
would you genuinely have stopped
drinking do you reckon because you've
obviously
been a lot of it's been around being on
the past benders and stuff but you've
obviously had a real good time
as a 19 year old would you have
committed to not drinking for your whole
career
well i haven't i've quit drinking two
times my life for like nine months
since one time i went 11 months right
mate it wasn't really the drink it was
more the um
[Music]
the temptation it was more the girls to
be honest bro yeah
i love girls i love every other man
and like you know they like me too so
they would tempt you into doing things
and partying and you just keep going and
honestly i i know i had a problem with
alcohol and [ __ ] but it's not like i was
an alcoholic it's not like i woke up
like needing a drink it was just once i
started partying
i just loved partying because there was
girls around i like that environment
i like talking to girls like that
connection maybe it's something i missed
in my childhood i don't know but i
really enjoyed
that woman connection so it was a big
distraction for me really big wasn't so
much the alcohol
it was more than a woman but the woman
and alcohol go hand in hand yeah you
know
to be honest i don't really like
drinking i love it but
the taste doesn't do it for me you know
you just do it because when it's
associated yeah exactly exactly my man
exactly yeah
what a journey the great robbie flynn
man i'd love to
like you so i'd love to go back um if we
could transport you back
10 12 years and just see what a play you
could have become knowing what you know
now
no doubt in my mind you would have been
in all black and potentially one of the
greats but
we can only look back and reflect now
and
but for you to come on here and share
what you've learned and share
your journey so honestly and openly it's
been awesome to hear
and i hope it's inspiring for everyone
else listening out there especially the
ones who are
hoping to become professional rugby
players listening to robbie and hearing
sort of what not to do and man the
regret that he has
wishing that he listened to the advice
that he had when he had the chance
um i think it's real powerful stuff and
i think it will change a lot of people's
uh future so really appreciate you
coming on the show bro and
and being so honest and open cheers to
romance i appreciate it man just good to
catch up with you good see your bloody
smiling face again man
to be honest uh yeah i hope it sends a
good message out there and i was a bit
raw and a bit honest and
mate but hey that's the truth eh and um
you know we all grow we all learn from
mistakes and we'll move on
and how is how you do that to be honest
we're all evolving as people and
you know i'm not finished yet so i'm
ready for my next chapter and
let's go that's it love your work
cheers brother thanks heaps sweet
brother
so real quick i have an offer for you
from puresport cbd to give you a perfect
chance to try this
unreal product it's certified for
athletes you can get it anywhere in the
world you are listening to this new
zealand included
and most importantly it works so the
offer is twenty percent off all you have
to do is type in what a lad with no
spaces with a 20 on the end
2-0 in the promo code and you're away